Hello, hello, BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today, we're your host of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you, Ruffians,
Join us for coming here to join us for your final weekday of the week!
What?
Why are you laughing?
I got confused.
I thought you were saying for your final FUWAMOCO Morning.
No!
Not the final.
Today is the 29th episode.
Whenever you say the final episode of the week, it always scares me and I think the ruffians are the same.
You're just trying to jumpstart the morning.
BAU BAU!
Well, for some first-time ruffians who thought they were here for their first FUWAMOCO Morning, but turned out to be their final and final one, I'll explain that.
FUWAMOCO Morning, it's a short format morning show and it's held every Friday today, Wednesday, and Monday.
Yeah, FUWAMOCO.
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Okay, please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag.
Hashtag, FUWAMOCO.
FWMCMORNING.
Okay.
Got it.
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Now first off, we already have
Another Pero Sighting!
De-den.
See the DVD?
It looks like a ruffian was doing some cleaning at work and found Pero between the DVDs.
Do you see ruffians on the left there?
Is he digital now?
But it's a DVD.
Not a CD, a DVD.
Okay, DVD Peron.
No matter how much we like all the physical media and having DVDs around, even now, we know that the times are for YouTube, right?
Yeah, DVD's time is over.
I don't know what Peron's thinking.
Sweet Peron.
And he's asking the ruffians to bring pudding.
No, Pero, you know!
YouTube!
No, it's YouTube!
Yeah, the title is not Bring Me Pudding, it's Please Like and Subscribe and all that, you know.
Hit the bell for notifications or something like that, right?
You've done that all, right, Ruffians?
Right?
Maybe the DVD times was Bring Me Pudding.
Maybe, maybe that was the thing then, but...
Yeah, I don't know.
He's trying in his own kind of way, but maybe it's a few decades late.
Am I too late?
I can't help but wonder what does happen if you bring him pudding though.
Well, Ruffian, you'll have to see and give it a shot for us, right?
See what happens.
But please prepare for the worst, too.
You know, it can be sort of rough sometimes seeing him try to eat the whole pudding on his own as fast as he can before he can grab it away from him.
We can be pretty desperate.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, thank you!
Thank you!
This is pretty cool though, DVD.
Please let us know if you see Pero around again!
Maybe next time it'll be a Blu-ray.
Oh, maybe.
That'll be the next best step up, right?
Next step up.
BAU BAU!
Wow, Ruffians, this weekend
Sighting!
In case you didn't know!
De-den!
On Sunday!
On Sunday at 8pm PT, 12pm JST, I, Senpai Iris, and all of FUWAMOCO will be having a special 3D showcase all together!
We're really excited to see everyone having fun in their 3D bodies all together this time!
You know, just like you ruffians, we're not too sure what to expect, but we sure will be able to see their strong bond all together in action, and hopefully, maybe, some singing and dancing.
Let's all go end it with a BIG BANG!
You'll get it if you miss it, okay?
Got it!
You'll be there, right?
BAU BAU!
Wow, we've also had some exciting things going on.
I saw the ruffians.
I don't know if any ruffians noticed though, because... You have to count.
Math is difficult.
It is.
We did for you.
Yeah, we did.
You know ruffians?
Are there some math ruffians out there?
Math ruffians?
It didn't work.
I see one ruffian that's called a math ruffian.
You know?
We have happy news because we've hit over 100 livestreams on YouTube!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU B
You know, considering it's been only two months and a bit or so, I think that's worth celebrating, you know?
But hopefully our math added up because it does sound kind of suspicious, too.
It does.
I did check multiple times because I thought that can't be right.
Anyways, it's been a very happy and fun filled 100 days with you, Ruffians.
Of course, we hope there's gonna be many many many many many many many more continuing on for a long long long long long long time.
Long long long long long long long long long long long long long long long long long long long time!
Bye!
You know, there's so many things we want to do, and lots of games we want to play with you, you know?
So no matter how tricky or rough things can be sometimes, we'll keep on trying and doing our best, okay?
You know?
We're stubborn.
Very hungry.
And we're puppies.
We're excited for everything still coming up.
Thank you for always being by our side and supporting us here, ruffians.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Happy, happy day.
Happy FUWAMOCO Morning!
Time to end it.
And not a happy note.
I wish it didn't have to be this way.
And not a happy note, right?
But I think we need to clear up this misunderstanding, right Moco-chan?
Yeah.
It's important.
Ruffians, you know, the other day we spent a while playing Resident Evil 4 Remake together, right?
Right.
And there were a lot of grandmas and grandpas everywhere we went.
Like that.
You know, we were thinking that...
There probably are some ruffians who might think that us, the FUWAMOCO, think that violence towards the elderly is okay.
It's not.
It's not!
Absolutely not!
Never ever ever ever!
We have to show our respect for them and help them when they need help too.
You know when they have scary eyes and are rotting and throwing axes and then bombs and then knives and are trying to bite us, you know?
Extreme measures might have to be taken, you know?
Yeah.
Extreme violence.
Extreme violence!
But otherwise, ruffians, let's make sure to be nice to the... the happy grandmas, the happy grandpas.
Happy grandma and grandpas, okay?
The ones without the scary eyes throwing knives and bombs and trying to fight us.
Yeah, make sure you don't get lost in their eyes, okay?
Understood?
Understood, ruffians?
Only in the game.
Got it.
Understood?
Okay.
BAU BAU!
It would be bad if the ruffians misunderstood that one, right?
What?
Was it yesterday?
Well, you know, I think it was during Resident Evil 4 too, but we also kinda shared with you the other day about how hard it can get in a studio human world.
It can get really really really hot.
It's a bit of a secret.
A bit of a secret, yeah.
I think doing Resident Evil 4, it got up to 32 degrees.
Very humid.
Very sticky.
Yeah, so that's why we can get pretty sweaty doing scary games.
Especially scary games.
Yeah, we're screaming and panicking, you know?
Yeah.
Moco-chan.
Moco-chan here.
Moco-chan has a secret that she's been keeping from you ruffians.
I haven't been keeping it from you, I just... I don't know.
Really?
Does it have to get shared?
I mentioned it yesterday.
Then you have to!
So... I don't know why, but...
It's FUWAMOCO-chan.
You can't keep the secret from the ruffians any longer.
Don't think about it, okay?
Don't use your brain, okay?
It's hot.
It's hot in the studio, but... For some reason, my toes are almost always really, really cold, okay?
Like, like ice cube cold.
So it can be pretty uncomfy.
So then... Don't say here it comes, okay?
So even if I'm really, really hot in general, then, you know, my toes are really cold.
So then... You know...
I have a special solution.
It's just for me.
Just for Mococo.
You know, I have a special foot warmer.
Underneath.
So that you know, I can keep my paws warm.
This way I'm comfy, I can focus, I'm all good.
You know.
It probably makes me a bit hotter, especially during games when I'm focusing on guard dog training, but
Maybe that just makes the training better and more effective.
But you know, sometimes I make a mistake.
And I turn up the heat too much by accident and then I have to remove my feet so that they don't start burning, you know?
Not a Fuwawa warmer, okay?
But you'll never know if that happens, okay?
Yeah.
My feet are burning!
No, no, no.
It's my secret, okay?
You know, I'm just hoping that the foot warmer doesn't break soon because I've been using it a lot!
But, it should be good.
It's kind of scary though, Moco-chan.
Sometimes you leave it on for so long.
Until you turn it off and you don't.
The only time I get sort of angry is when it goes off.
Because it's just on a timer.
It's an eight hour timer, no?
Yeah, and sometimes it goes off and then I get sad.
I don't know, I think it's a hazard, ruffians.
It's good.
At least you know when you use the foot warmer then Moco-chan will accidentally touch me with her cold toes.
True.
That's the happy part.
Just wear socks!
No.
BAU BAU!
That was my secret.
Do you feel better?
Ruffians, do you feel better now that Moco-chan finally told you her secret?
You better.
What are slippers, Moco-chan?
They make me frustrated.
She leaves them everywhere.
I have slippers!
I just forget them everywhere, okay?
Let's continue.
Ruffians!
We have... It's been two months since our debut, right?
And today's our 101st... First... Livestream.
But the day is finally here!
Ruffians!
We have... Our very first... Gumi Livestream!
Is this how it's done?
Ruffians, this is how we're gonna do it.
You know we told you yesterday, we didn't really feel like we got quite enough of a Suica game, right?
We're gonna play more Suica game!
Watermelon!
We're gonna be doing it shortly after Rock n' Rawr Party tomorrow at 1AM PST.
5AM JST.
I'm sorry, 5PM JST.
We really didn't feel like we were able to show off all our skills yesterday.
So hopefully, you know, this time we can get a new high score and be the top dogs of Suica Game and Holo EN.
Ruffians, you think we can do it?
The score only counts if it's on stream, right?
And I think it's much more fun playing together with you, ruffians, than off stream.
There's not much of a point.
But we also do know that the time might be a bit difficult for some ruffians to join us.
But don't worry because they'll be in the archive there waiting for you too.
It'll be okay, okay?
Don't worry, don't worry, don't worry, don't worry, okay?
But I'm just looking forward to being able to satisfy our watermelon baby.
Yeah, we need to see the watermelon more.
Right, we didn't even see him for a second.
He was there but then gone.
This time for sure.
BAU BAU!
We hope that you'll be there if you can.
But don't force yourself, okay?
BAU BAU!
I think it's time for us to move to a regular corner today.
We have our Doggie of the Day.
And it is... This is the Doggie of the Day!
A cute girl.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU B
Ruffians!
I wonder, you know, how did she get her nose so glowing and lustrous?
It's like shiny.
Like something you put on a tree for Christmas.
We didn't get her name, though.
What should it be?
Do we name her now?
Ruffians, do you have a name?
Omega Fluff.
I feel like something like Florence would work well.
Florence, is that a girl name?
It sounds fluffy.
Florence.
Fluffington.
Flora.
Florenza.
Flufferina?
I kinda like that.
Florenza.
Florenza it is.
Fluffy.
Oh, I like the spelling.
Florenza is decided.
All the ruffians like it.
Fuwa!
What?
I like it.
Fuwa.
F-O-O-F-A.
Is that like a Moomin?
No, it's a Fuwa.
She's Fuwa.
BAU BAU Fuwa!
Decided.
Well, how did Fuwa BAU BAU do?
We got distracted, huh?
I think it'd be like...
I guess that makes sense.
You know, she probably doesn't want to BAU BAU that often because, you know... She just wants to smile.
I'm well-mannered, so... Maybe a bit quieter, maybe like... BAU BAU!
I think she's a beauty and a best friend.
I'm a little envious.
Do you think we'll ever even get close to her level, Moco-chan?
I don't know.
We have to work hard.
But she's cute!
She's beautiful!
Advent.
And we should be both making each other smile a lot tonight.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Did a ruffian go out for a little journey for a walk?
I hope so.
Let's take a look.
De-den!
What type of walk is this?
This is both the scariest and bravest walk I've ever seen a ruffian go on.
Please be safe.
Yeah, you know, taking shortcuts late at night is sort of strange, but you know, at least haunted.
That brings me a bit concerned, you know?
What's with that?
BAU BAU.
It is fun to go out for late-night walks, but you know, Moco-chan and I, we're both too scaredy for that.
It's dark there.
You also have to make sure to stay safe, guys.
Safety, safety.
Yeah, make sure others know where you are and that you wear reflective clothing during the night time.
You know, maybe a bear whistle or something too might be good.
Right?
Yeah, but it'll be really hard for others to see you, so let's make sure that we're keeping ourselves safe, okay?
Right!
Alright.
Safety is important, okay?
We wouldn't want anything to happen to you, okay, ruffians?
BAU BAU.
I guess it's good for not letting the spooky things get to you and stop you from going on a- Get to you?
Spooky things get to you?
Well, like, you know, like your heart.
Your heart.
BAU BAU!
We got a question from a ruffian, Moco-chan.
Let's take a peek at it.
De-den!
I remember you doggos expressing your love for cute scale figures.
Would it be possible for you to discuss or share your collection?
I got into figure collecting from being a long time lover of anime, so I'd definitely be interested in hearing more about it.
Thank you!
Thank you for the question.
We love scale figures too!
But you know, we haven't bought anything for a long time.
You know, they used to be pretty affordable and obtainable with the same kind of quality as the ones we produce now, but you know, they used to be around maybe 4,000, 5,000, 6,000 yen.
We bought them used though, right?
But now the ones now, they have like a crazy long pre-order to production to release window.
Like a year and a half, right?
But you know, we're sure that's because the ones are much smaller.
Things have probably improved greatly since then too.
You know if you don't pre-order it, sometimes you just can't get it.
We're not ready, we're not ready for that.
I can't think that far ahead.
But you know, we really like the large scale figures.
Like 1 sixth or bigger.
1 eighth is nice, but 1 seventh is like the sweet spot.
But anything bigger is like, I'm excited for this one.
But you know with figures, it's really nice because you're able to have your favorite character in 3D, in your living space.
It's really happy.
It was really fun.
You know, we are able to see everyone's garage kits that they put so much love and passion into.
Garage kits are like the, just the parts.
The parts that you can make yourself.
You use resin.
Resin.
Yeah.
And then you paint them with airbrushes and stuff.
Put them together, pin them, all that stuff.
Sanding.
Very, very cool.
Glue.
And make sure that you're wearing the goggles and that you have ventilation.
All that stuff.
Very cool.
You know, we'd like to build them someday too.
Especially with Fuwawa and the humidifier, I feel like it might be dangerous.
It's important to have good lungs.
But we actually own a few very special garage kits.
But we first want to ask someone who knows what they're doing to build them and paint them for us, I think.
We never trust ourselves to do a good job.
Especially, you know, if they're special and old.
You can't get those anymore.
They've been gone forever.
We have it on our big goal list too, but we hope that one day we can become figures too!
And that way, you know, you can feel as happy as us seeing us in your room as we do the characters we love.
But besides scale figures, we have Nendoroids.
They're really cute too.
You know what?
I... Wait...
Demon guard dogs, not puppies, but you know, we were actually remembering.
Thinking about trying to collect all Nendoroids when they started coming out too.
But it's for the best, we didn't try that.
But there are so many cute ones, and we have more than that.
We do have a lot.
But it would have been a journey.
Especially our Senpai Nendoroids too.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
It's always a good question.
Thank you for all your submissions today, ruffians!
Remember.
Remember what?
You don't remember.
I don't remember.
I want to remind the ruffians.
FUWAMOCO Morning is something that we make all together.
So, we want to say thank you always for your submissions.
And we want to remind you too that we're looking forward to seeing more of your Doggie of the Day.
To seeing the walks that you're going on.
Even if they're spooky.
Right?
Receiving your burning questions.
Exactly.
Maybe getting more Pero sightings too.
Hopefully Pero stays out of your hair.
And don't forget to use the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
Our next theme!
We have...
De-den!
We're teaming up again with Advent!
And we're gonna be doing some more Left 4 Dead 2 today.
Hopefully this time we don't get Left 4 Dead.
Last time was rough huh?
It was rough.
I'll never forget it.
I think we caught a hang of the melee combat.
I think I did!
Do you think we're ready to use the katana to cut through more zombies?
BAU BAU!
Is that a war cry?
Well, let's take a look at our schedule!
We have our schedule!
And tomorrow we'll be having another rock n' rawr party together with you!
We've got kind of a better idea of what we want to sing this time now.
I think it's going to be a mix of everything!
More than anything we just want to have a lot of fun all together so we picked a bunch of our karaoke favorites and also some newer songs too.
Please join us, okay?
Get ready to howl a lot!
Don't forget our Suika game after that too, okay?
It's not on there because it's gorilla.
Yeah, gorilla.
Gorilla, but no bananas, just watermelons.
Just watermelons.
Oh, that's true.
We got our banana gorillas and our watermelon gorillas.
All the gorillas.
We're dogs.
BAU BAU!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us today for another FUWAMOCO Morning and the last FUWAMOCO Morning of this week.
Thank you!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our extra special Ruffians today!
I'm using my eyes, but... Miraizou!
BAU BAU!
Fuki!
Potato!
BAU BAU!
Tatsuko!
Mic Drop!
BAU BAU!
Moonlight!
Waltz!
BAU BAU!
Wax!
And to every other ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!